I'm [ __ ] working around here
[Music]
morning vlog 7:00 a.m.
ahead to Jose Eber to our client meeting
and head back to city all day meetings
until about 10:00 p.m. last night went
to Cleveland had a great time
Cavs game Cavs Celtics big shots Gordon
Hayward so sorry about your injury man
hope you get better no super gruesome
you saw it out yeah yeah Wow I'm big
love to everybody everybody has a great
productive day
it's gonna be another grinder just kind
of how it is Dana life most of mark
party
[Music]
[Music]
and that's always think that fascinates
person you talked to
well clip sir yeah right after we left
it sounds like Philip just gave me the
job
pumped up right after he like swooped
around the bar and then like totally
change the way interacting
that is interesting that's actually
exactly right
the context
good I got home late last night since I
was in Cleveland so it was mainly a
little rolling session this morning but
good abri every day every day some this
week
yeah like I just need to not break the
pattern
even if it's a day like today
[Music]
love this of the green of this of the
cork time
inside
these are super rad
but I think I'll you got to get a pair
yes accidents traffic
something to care control
[Music]
meantime come here
okay that was fun
[Music]
Jeffrey we're gonna sleep up thank you
this is why this whole thing's gonna
work for us every time somebody cares
about their money we win as I embark on
my fifth business book and because five
is my favorite number I just want to
make sure I acknowledge the team the
thing that I most value the world which
is my family
from amazing wife Lizzie and my music
kids missions and her to my unbelievable
parents Sasha
tomorrow and the rest of my siblings and
in-laws about brothers and
sister-in-laws I am I'm only able to
live this anomaly because of the
infrastructure and the love that you
guys support me with and so thank you
from the bottom of my heart this is
dedicated to all the people that are
brave enough to attempt the ability to
go out and live their life and actually
recognize the enormous opportunity we
all have in this new digital age to have
a balance of happiness not only in their
life but in their work
cool Kyle you're not getting much it's
just been meeting after meeting just
keep be rolling the [ __ ] out of this
vlog I'll figure out how to make this an
entertaining episode for you but I'm
[ __ ] working around here
[Music]
what's up blog as you could tell by the
b-roll that Kyle's gonna bang out today
was an obnoxiously busy day did a bunch
of 90-day reviews every 90 days I get
together with my Anna blog the Savannah
one of my favorite favorite employees at
vaynermedia to choose finally feels like
sex I just came from gym do you think
it's weird that you'll be on the blog in
the kind of gym red face yeah just out
of gym class like two seconds need to
kill it yeah good hi how are you
pleasure good to see you well you're
gonna ever say hi to me or this is my
open-door policy issue that I've been
talking about I need to see you more
often
you always promised that he never did
please you good yeah oh well yes how are
you
thank you brother of course love it man
hey what's your name hey thanks for love
thank you so much it said everything you
post and all things to say Thank You
Bennet I wish you well okay got it
so busy day all day every 90 days I get
together my team diminutive the lots of
stuff client stuff great day super busy
and so what I want to do is I want to
set up this talk I gave at Bloomberg for
a Cornell tech very much the state of
the union of a lot of thoughts on my
mind a lot of things that are going on
with the tech space the entrepreneurs
face the attention of consumer space
engaging with your employees Anna
engaging with people that are consuming
your content Steve I've been just super
interesting stuff I hope you enjoy it
one of the sharper kind of different
angled fireside chats that I've done in
a while and I hope you sit back pop a
glass of red wine and watch this Jerry
yes very straightforward let's start
with uncovering your strengths lots of
people want to be Gary Vee but they
can't so let's talk about self-awareness
and when you figured out that you are an
exceptional communicator um you know not
until later you know I think you know
it's funny lots of people want to be
Gary Vee I think lots of people want to
really figure themselves out and put
them in a position to be happy and
successful so when I hear that I mean I
think I don't think a lot of people want
to be me I think I put myself really out
there and a lot of baggage comes along
with that and so I think personalities
are different what you know but it's
interesting to think about your
circumstances I I mean I was 31 years
old running a retail e-commerce wine
business in New Jersey like I didn't
I've never been to Silicon Valley like
this is a lot has happened very quickly
on the back of me understanding where
consumer attention is and probably about
a year into Wine Library TV in 2006 I
started a wine video blog show around
wine on YouTube in YouTube's really
early days and about six months in I'm
like wow a lot of people are watching
this and it was because I was talking
about wine in a very different way and I
genuine believe a lot of entrepreneurs
and people listen to me because I think
I'm undereducated in some ways you know
I don't know the way a lot of things are
said or done because I was very much a
street immigrant kind of kid more I
wasn't a good student and it was I just
kind of look at things a lot of times
for the first time right and I think
some way somehow and because my grant my
mom's dad basically only spoke in
analogies from what I what my mom talks
about him and I do that quite a bit
I feel like you know my dad doesn't talk
he says what do you mean he doesn't talk
so my dad and I drove 45 minutes to wine
library and back when I was a teen shot
discount liquors back in day I lived 45
minutes I lived in Hunterdon County New
Jersey for my high school years and my
dad's wine store was in Short Hills
Milburn so it's 45 minutes on route 78
in Jersey and we would drive all the way
there and all the way back and I talked
every minute and my dad didn't say a
word so my dad's an old-school Russian
guy you know in Russia communist Russia
you didn't talk because have you said
something that somebody found out you
went to jail I mean like let's get to
the punchline there's a lot of reasons
my dad doesn't talk but yeah I mean
trying to you know being in a setting
like that where like you're building
something in a business environment
together but uh but somebody's not
communicating back to you definitely
honed I think intuitive skills I already
had
improv skills I already had they
probably made him hyper and and yeah you
know at this point I really understand
it but I'm really bad at like cheering
things or observing them like I do them
in real time those numbers point where I
sat down and thoughtfully was like wow I
have this or this is important I'm aware
of it I try not to get too high or too
low about any of these things but it's
definitely a disproportionate impact on
my career but not only as like the
public persona on the one-to-one
relationships I have with my employees
and my family members you know being a
good communicator is a pretty fruitful
you know skill set and as Dan was saying
you learn by doing and you've formed
multiple businesses this communication
skill has allowed you to do this from
Wine Library to Vayner sports to the
hosts of multiple digital programs which
of these different businesses do you do
for love versus for money I speak for
love I do this for love like this is the
place I love the most like being in it
you know public speaking is now an ROI
negative event for me with the things
that are going on in my life even though
it is still crazy to me when I get paid
to do a speech you know especially when
you come from zero it's gray no getting
paid to give a speech
one day this year making more money than
I made when I was 30 years old is a
pretty intense kind of thing that you'd
wrap your head around but I get but it's
still not worth my time in a lot of ways
now unless it's leading to business
generation for vaynermedia or other
things which is really what I've now
mainly do but I'll do something like in
New York or support organizations I
believe in but I do this for love I love
the thought that I'm like so knowing all
of the so I love reverse engineering the
audience so I'm in a very funny zone
right now in this talk in this talk it's
less about entertainment like 18,000
people at an off-site for a company
tonight's about okay I really want to be
sharp and talk about three or four
things that I think even a really strong
crowd like this isn't thinking enough
about because I'm always trying to leave
with giving more value than the person
expected right so this I do for love
the Gary Vee thing the public persona I
think I do for love
the most ok Vayner sports [ __ ] sports
is a business that is very interesting
because my brother has Crohn's disease
and so he left vaynermedia two years ago
because the stress have gone from 30 to
800 people was pretty intense and he
just didn't like it anymore and if
anybody hears in client service you're
just managing people and if you don't
like managing people it sucks [ __ ]
right and so he got to that place and he
needed to bounce and he needed time for
himself and very quickly he came back
and said what about that sports agency
we bought I bought a sports agency a
very small one just to learn you know
I've very substantial ambitions to buy
the New York Jets so I figured if I if I
owned a sports agency I'll learn I
learned from the inside I was gonna lose
money every year owning a boutique
sports agency that I wasn't gonna be
really involved with to learn uh but
then he wanted to do that and once he
decided he wanted to really be involved
I felt comfortable and rebranding into
Vayner sports putting our name on it it
was gonna be real uh I love it I mean
I'm talking to 50 of the top 100
football players that are gonna come
into the NFL
next year I'm DM right now it's fun I
like it it's interesting it's an awful
business makes no sense it's stupidest
business going like like just a terrible
business model sports agencies you have
to have unbelievable scale for it even
to become somewhat interesting my
brother's doing it for love I'm doing it
for the love of my brother now your
philosophy as you pursue all these
different avenues is that 9 to 5 working
9 to 5 is for losers if you want to be
productive not you well it's for it's
for someone who isn't gonna get where
they want to do get know the and I
appreciate you bring it up and listen
the times razz me the other day on this
in a pretty substantial way I when I
when I talk about things context is lost
sometimes I'm at fault sometimes people
that report on is are at fault to make
it very clear here's my thing I'm
fascinated by people that complain if
you don't complain I actually have
nothing to say to you I don't I don't
think I'm entitled to I don't you
clearly have no reason to really listen
if you're good you're good
and if that's 9:00 to 5:00 and you're on
for softball fields and you're loving
life then you've won my big thing is in
this era of everybody saying they're
gonna be billionaire
and they're entrepreneurs and they're
the best and I'm the next [ __ ] sucks
right and you're going to Coachella and
you're going to you know every summit at
sea and you're just not working like my
thing that's intriguing I think I am NOT
I don't think people are losers I don't
think people shouldn't sleep I think
your actions should match your mouth and
your ad and your ambitions that's what
I'm interested in and I think that we
have a very broken system right now of
entrepreneurial tendencies because
there's a lot of money in the system and
it's a very intriguing time so I think I
think working 9:00 to 5:00 is for a
loser that says that they're gonna rule
the world and they watch Netflix for
four hours a day but if you want to
start your own business if you want to
be the next Gary Vee it takes more than
working 9:00 to 5:00 you got to put in
the time you've got to hustle I think so
I think it's super hard to build a
substantial sustainable you know safe
business working 9:00 to 5:00 if I mean
look let me release it again you can
work 9:00 to 5:00 you really can you
know I just think that hard work is an
unbelievably controllable variable
compared to the serendipity of the
marketplace the god-given talent you
have
it's see it's a very important variable
that I think is is a differentiator if
you want to be successful and I see a
lot of people resting on their laurels
that they may have some success and
their past and what I'm worried about is
technologies created infrastructure that
has not allowed us to rest on our
advantages not even the biggest
companies in the world the biggest
retailers in the world the biggest media
companies world are on call you and your
little caca medium business are good get
out of here and so like you know that's
it
it's a differentiator but what happens
for people who don't have the time the
resources I mean I'm a working mom how
on earth am I supposed to do my day job
talk to you get home deal with my kids
make sure that they have enough to eat
for the next day prepare their lunch and
then use my remaining hours to come up
with something that I'm passionate about
well do you want to build a business
it's not I'm saying for whatever I
pursue and yes if if that means
going down that road later on so I just
think life's about options right like
everybody's got stuff like to me the
fact that you even have the ability to
build a business between 9:30 p.m. and
1:00 o'clock in the morning is
remarkable because your grandmother
didn't the Internet has allowed that to
actually be even a debate you know our
grandparents grew up in environment
where that became Campina you were
opening a business at 9:30 p.m. right
like the fact that we even have the
ability even to debate that is
fascinating to me and I'm not naive that
there is extreme circumstances for many
people and that people are starting
further along than others ah my point on
that has always been it's just
remarkable that you can do so much
between 7:00 p.m. and 2:00 in the
morning to change the outcome of your
life the end and and that's it I mean
it's not super it's not super difficult
to understand its the options that we
are now awarded by the infrastructure of
scalable technologies that have no cost
of entry to build a personal brand or a
small business direct-to-consumer is
just fascinating to me you shouldn't
it's not other people have better
advantages than you you're also more
than welcome to take a different job
make less money take a step back live a
little less fancy for four years and
build your business well the thing that
we never talk about is to step back a
lot of people say to me and they come at
me and they're like yeah but I've got
this and this and I'm like cool but if
you're so upset and you want to build
this business why not go for making 180
a year 297 you've opened up a lot of
time why don't you sell your home and go
rent an apartment why don't you go
[ __ ] not buy 4 different outfits
every month and buy one a year you can
life's about options there's a lot of
ways to do this the last time you
stepped back but vaynermedia is a step
back hell how 7 years ago I just come on
the back of investing in Facebook and
Twitter and Tumblr I was one of the
hundred most followed people on Twitter
I had all sorts of opportunities I could
have raised hundreds of millions of
dollars for a fund on the back of being
an early angel investor that was fancy I
was rolling I had a lot of things going
for me and I decided to take a step back
and start vaynermedia
because I thought it would be an amazing
infrastructure for me to build on top of
in my fifties and sixties so I mean I
make a lot less money and eat a lot more
[ __ ] by running vaynermedia than the
options that were in front of me 70
years ago he took the boring approach I
took an extremely boring approach that a
lot of my friends that are fancy you
still make fun of definitely made fun of
at the time now a lot of them gone out
of business so they make less fun and
and and you know what to be very frank
the garyvee thing started getting big
and I was didn't like that I was a
motivational speaker I had so much pride
that as a 22 year old kid I took my
dad's business with no money and grew it
substantially in a very significant way
and I thought of myself as a businessman
not as this personality or this new-age
motivational speaker so I think I even
needed it for myself to build another
business to just scratch that itch that
I wasn't a charlatan or a personality
that I that I had chops who just
happened to be a little narcissistic and
over the top for those who have figured
out they're passionate they want a sort
of business they're ready to take the
leap the question for a lot of them is
how do they tell that story in a
captivating way how do they convince
others that they're there and they're
the real thing for the purpose of
raising capital for the purpose of
getting awareness both well first you
have to figure out if you're capable are
you good enough at writing audio or
video to communicate your story you have
to find your medium first there's a lot
of people that can capita me Fred Wilson
has built a lot of brand equity in a lot
of deal flow through writing through
writing I I created it through video
right Joe Rogan and Tim Ferriss continue
to build it on audio right so there's
three ways to communicate when you start
getting into cartooning and art you can
go a little bit further there's three
core ways there's written audio and
video first and foremost you can't be
romantic about which one a lot of people
want to be good at video or this and
that you know so a you have to figure
out if you can actually tell a story and
then to you have to figure out the
medium in which you can tell a story and
if you can do it in more than one places
that would be preferable because our
attention is fragmented at scale so
that's the strategy behind it so how do
you decide which is the best medium
because there's different things
that come into fashion go out of fashion
I mean if you pause too long you'll miss
it my answer is to do with them all hate
it all if you can you know look I think
I don't think people have really audited
how much downtime they have if they want
it I mean this is all comes down to
ambition reverse engineering the actual
ambition you know it's fine if you want
a panda in front of friends or relatives
or other people you even really have a
real conversation with yourself and you
also need to realize it's going to
change when you're 22 and you're single
and you're on fire and your older
brother's killing it you want to [ __ ]
prove it and your parents and yourself
and I said you get married you fall in
love you have a kid you have a sick kid
priorities changed life is life a lot
happens so not only do you have to talk
to yourself and figure out what your
ambition is you have to actually audit
that on a daily basis at least on a
monthly basis and it keeps changing it
keeps changing I mean I took more days
off this August then I did in my entire
20s combined why cuz I've made five year
old and that's what's more important to
me at this moment
and at in my 20s I was so on fire I
didn't want to go to the Jersey Shore
and hook up I wanted to build something
you know and like things change now I
kind of want to go to the Jersey you
know but you know like I think you know
I think things change and I think that
you need to be prepared for that I'm
just fascinated on words pandering and
actions I'm fast I spent a lot of time
on this because it helps people when you
suffocate them and tell them they're
foolish it or their right like it's an
important conversation when you're
tricking yourself you've got a real
problem
yeah what you mentioned how things
change and there are different mediums
you could try to do all three at the
same time you're probably not gonna be
good at all three you'll be better on
one thing than another
yes the response that you get though I
mean it all comes down to understanding
human behavior because that part doesn't
change how people respond to a message
that's right and I genuinely believe the
reason that I've popped over the last
decade is I'm completely obsessed with
giving more to my audience than I ask
for in return period and it's storied
forever that's just the truth I really
you know I see a lot of faces here I
feel a lot of vibes from you like I'm
not asking for anything I'm putting out
the best stuff I've
got for free everyday there's no it's
not a top of funnel to get you into my
$400 ebook it's not a top of funnel to
get you to come and visit my Island for
twenty five thousand dollars for the
weekend
it's [ __ ] purely can I guilt you
because I gave you so much that I asked
for nothing in return that it creates
word-of-mouth can I be historically
correct can I just bring so much value
its ultimate brand arbitrage does it
work a hundred percent because so few
people do it cuz they're not good enough
to do it give us an example of when it
worked it's my own for who for me
mmm-hmm
I mean I think it's my it worked because
I made a video that said Twitter's
dangerous to Facebook it was a good
thoughtful piece of content that led to
Zach's asking me through Dave Morin to
fly out to Facebook and talk to their
company when they were this size I
talked about human behavior in 2007 the
whole time I didn't know anything about
mark and realized how much of an EQ guy
he really was - I didn't know he was in
the room like this he walked down from
somewhere over there when I was done he
asked me if I could have dinner with him
we had dinner that night and four months
later I bought a bunch of his parents
stock and made tens of millions of
dollars okay that's a pretty good story
that's a good one you know right
same with Tumblr David Karp saw a piece
of content about how I thought about
engagement it led to a couple drinks in
the city then he came out to Wine
Library and the B round of tumbler was
fourteen million dollar valuation and I
invested very aggressively and made lots
and lots of money I I made a piece of
content about brands and Facebook that
Mike Lazaro saw I gave him a quote for
buddy media's landing page when they
launched and I made seven figures in
advisory equity for a quote on his
website on the back of a piece of
content you still own stakes in those
companies
no I begs it at all right tumblr so T
Yahoo made money Facebook Facebook I own
every single share still I'm gonna end
up making more money on Facebook than
some of the early atop 100 employees
because I knew what Facebook was when it
went public you understood the mission
I think sucks is an all-time
entrepreneur he trades attention like I
do except he's way further along and he
can buy the companies that are the
infrastructure of it but he stole
Instagram right I got made fun
for saying that the day that happened he
tried to buy snapchat long before
anybody gave a [ __ ] he he invests in VR
he moved a desktop company to full
mobile when it was painful and cost
prohibitive he understands consumer
behavior he is an extremely all time
EQ operator that people think is an
introverted nerd but he's also gotten a
lot of negative attention and Facebook
as well it's the company's mired in the
government's Russia investigation Asst
there's a lot of anger towards big tech
companies yes towards founders like Mark
Zuckerberg who don't go through college
and now head up this big company they're
billionaires the left the far left the
far right have kind of teamed up
together and their anger towards big
tech yes
what's the road ahead for Facebook how
does it navigate that how do you how do
you see the company surviving this we're
driving easily you know I don't know the
details you know if they've done
something horribly wrong they should pay
the price but how did I see them
surviving it pretty darn easily what
about all the public backlash yeah
easily like everybody's using Instagram
more like people people like to say [ __ ]
they don't act on it everybody here
loves to throw up some sort of tweet and
think they're doing a social justice
move why don't you [ __ ] do something
about it people talk I mean it it's
super important like all my the day over
was the worst and everybody was on
subscribing and it's terrible and like I
watched four to five six people that I
knew in my office and friends like
unsubscribed I hate it and then
literally because I'm curious kind of
like tagged it and then just watch them
take an uber a week later we are so full
of [ __ ] it's scary and all that big
technology is doing is exposing us not
changing us and we're gonna have to go
through a painful hundred years of
understanding how full of [ __ ] we really
are do you think government regulators
will clamp down on the likes of Facebook
on Google in a way that will change how
we interact with those platforms
I think it's possible you know I never
underestimate politicians because I
don't respect them a whole lot do they
understand the platforms
uh they may or they may not but they
will only behave in their best interest
so I'm not sure you mention uber yeah I
want to bring that up because of some of
the mistakes you made you pass up
investing in uber how many times twice
in the angel round for million dollar
valuation maybe that's not so bad now
given that they're kind of challenged
yeah I mean they're challenged but it
would have been a solid bet yeah it's an
interesting time at uber you know Travis
is one of my dear dear friends one of
the first friends I made in tech and
it's been really intense to watch what
he's going through and the thing with me
is you know and this is a tough
interview for me because the truth is I
don't even have the first detail yet
about Facebook and Russia I swear to God
I know it's in the ecosystem I haven't
even been I really don't like headline
reading I really don't like it like I as
I become educated as I'm super educated
I'm really in a good place in three
places the current state of like tech
like consumer tech right like I really
understand snapchat and Instagram and
musically like I'm a practitioner I
really understand it there's a lot of
people here I have opinions on it never
done snapchat ad or things like I really
understand it I really understand wine I
really understand it and I really
understand the New York Jets right and
when I hear people talk about those
three things even smart people I'm
fascinated by when you're really great
at your craft how much smarter you are
than somebody that's even good right
I've gotten really quiet about most
things because I realize I might be
somewhat of a headline reader kind of a
headline reader like I've lost all um in
the last five years to talk about most
issues because I'm like wait a minute if
I sound this stupid like the way my
friends that are super smart about
Facebook ads and Instagram influencers
and snapchat if I sound like this around
health care or this or that I must like
so you know it's interesting the uber
thing's really interesting for me I have
a lot of emotions because I really adore
him I understand there's a lot of things
that in the press that have been tough
there's a lot of stuff that's tough for
me to like to like you know I'm hopeful
right when you care about somebody
obviously it's not there anymore which
is tough it will be interesting to watch
the
Londyn things super fascinating i don't
know the details sure it's a lot of
politics behind it it'll be interesting
it's an interesting company you said you
really understand snapchat yes but the
poem would snap is that whatever
innovation it comes up with Facebook can
replicate it and do it bigger and
splashy er yes how did they go up
against a behemoth like Facebook they
have to innovate in a way that it's not
a feature a feature is not the way you
innovate right the cats out of the bag
fast following features are now going to
be a way that is not going to allow the
house parties or the Marco Polo's or the
next frontier of things to get there so
they're gonna have to give it some
thought what's ironic about that his
Snap is uniquely potentially a company
that could do that because Evan and I
don't know him at all I've never met
Evan I know a lot of em ron's and a lot
of the other characters but he's he's an
L a kid he he's treated snapchat like a
fashion brand as much as a tech company
he actually could go left-field like
like you know if I set you that it was
snap not adidas that did what they've
done for the last two years to put Nike
in a weird spot it wouldn't seem that
far-fetched I get where you could be
like mmm but it's not as far-fetched
that if I said Twitter or you know or
Facebook or uber did that right and so
that's where I'm fascinated what snap is
gonna do or not gonna do we're about to
find out if Evan was a one-trick pony or
if he could adjust to the reality of a
new marketplace
they've quietly invested very
aggressively in AR you know when you
look at their M&A so be interesting to
see if they can or will do anything
there and then the other question is
this right which is Snap is an
incredibly big platform that has can
build a very big business it's just that
the market put all of the value into
that it was going to continue to grow
and be 30 40 50 60 year olds so what's
fascinating what snap is gonna be that
it's probably overvalued in a Wall
Street dynamic even even amongst
everything being overvalued they're
gonna have to do something they're gonna
have to truly innovate and it will be
interesting to see if they can do it but
again you know from ERISA buys Instagram
for a billion instead of
or who knows what could have happened
right like you're always that's what's
amazing about business you're always one
good or one bad move away from changing
the narrative and I love that about this
game like I never get caught up and it's
going well and I'm in this fancy
building and all these amazing people
are looking at me right now tomorrow it
can be the beginning of the complete end
I love that it doesn't matter what I've
done for 20 years how does how does
Twitter change the narrative it's the
user growth has slowed down tremendously
it's kind of become a niche product it's
it's not panning out the way a lot of
investors had hoped it's now looking to
expand up the character limit to 280
from 140 I don't know if this is gonna
make a big difference yeah that's not
gonna be it right I think we can all
agree with that but I do think since Jax
penny look and dick is one of my
favorite people on earth but in that
four years
the product didn't innovate once the
product just did not innovate and so at
least since Shaq's been back for the
lacy 18 months or whatever it's been
there's been little subtle things I mean
literally I mean four and I know there's
a lot of people in this room like
remember like it was literally four or
five years literally same exact product
even like the star to heart or like
retweet like little sidled subtle things
I thought it was super interesting what
Twitter was doing when they were buying
up all the rights because I thought they
were actually building a true Netflix
competitor as an OTT player I just don't
know if they have the right talent in
place to navigate it to be that but I
thought it was the right idea I do think
that Facebook and snap and Twitter are
absolutely the potential OTT challengers
of the future and I thought they were
earlier to move on that than the others
but they needed to move smarter better
faster and I and I feel like they didn't
they just ended up doing a six execution
or four instead of the ten they needed
to really get there do you think we're
in a bubble when it comes to these big
tech companies and how much money we're
throwing at them and and what investors
expect from them
I think Amazon and Facebook are grossly
underpriced explain I think Jeff Bezos
and Mark Zuckerberg as long as they
don't die are gonna make them grossly
underpriced
what's amazon's next move being sued by
the government amazon is so incredible i
remember four or five years ago at a
keynote writer and I don't remember if
Steve Jobs had passed away or was sick
or but I remember saying that I thought
Bezos was better than Steve Jobs and I
got really booed and this was the height
of Apple and Amazon was four or five
years ago which is not what we think
about Amazon today but it was but but
AWS sawdust you know like like the way
he bought like even the losses like
LivingSocial and woot and he was just
doing things and I was like [ __ ] man
Bezos has moves right like like like
Steve Jobs says all-time but he had the
same move rinse and repeat in a lot of
ways if you understand how I'm kind of
framing it Bezos was throwing all sorts
of different you know it's kind of like
the difference between like boxing and
MMA and I was like Jeff like like he ki
do any I think he could do anything like
I woke up and like Amazon buy his whole
foods I'm like yep like you know like
tomorrow if I wake up like Amazon buys
to get in the NHL I'm like mm-hmm
you know like like I think everything is
white space for him I think he is
absolutely the guy I'm so impressed with
their execution I'm I'm so excited to
watch them to do more stuff and I'm
genuinely hopeful that they understand
how to navigate so that the government
doesn't stop them because they feel to
me more than any company as the company
that could because I think that could
win the whole [ __ ] thing there you
have the damn the stack when you start
understanding what when you start
understanding that Alexa is this close
to becoming the next search engine when
you understand that when you're brushing
your teeth and you run out of it and
you're like Alexa reorder it for me like
when you start understanding what
they're doing the way they're putting
their pieces together when you
understand when you're watching Thursday
Night Football and Dez Bryant scores a
touchdown and at the height of your
emotion you can order his Jersey by
saying Alexa order that Jersey or like
or whatever they tell you to do while
you're watching because they're
full-stack they are an unbelievably
crafty business
he buys underpriced things buying the
Washington Post at the time like that
Washington Post in Boston Globe trade at
the time of newspapers biggest demise
the brand was so much more worth than
this to put it on the tablet whether the
fire worked or not it was irrelevant it
was the right thesis and and here's the
thing about great
trip Norse weather oculus is right or
not it's the right thesis when you're a
great entrepreneur and you're betting
like that you have to be right once out
of every eight times to make the whole
thing work great entrepreneurs do not
care about their losses because their
daring losses right and average
entrepreneurs and non entrepreneurs
always care about other people's
opinions about their losses good to
remember good to keep in mind all right
let's get to lightning round where we're
just basically have a lot of random
questions I want to get Gary's opinion
on what's the most overrated new
technology consumer VR and let me
explain why for us right now as a
practical function
I believe in consumer VR I just don't
think you're gonna see a lot of
consumers really doing impactful VR
stuff the way you want to over the next
36 to 48 months you still don't know a
single person that spends a good hour a
day in VR hardcore right do you know
anyone the tech community who does yeah
I'm sure there's some hardcore like
people like like it's funny the first PR
people I was meeting like 18 months ago
they were so nerdy I'm like okay this is
good like these are real nerds again
this isn't the club promoters have
[ __ ] up tap these are nerds you know
so that was cool but um yeah I mean I
don't like I really don't even know of a
story of something it's not there yet
so I think consumer VR is gonna lose a
lot of money for a lot of people it's a
great b2b thing it's great to go to the
Super Bowl and like do a brand
activation but nobody's sitting at home
for an hour on VR yet for real and I
don't think that's gonna happen for
another 3-4 years like real and it could
like and that to me it feels like
overrated
I we all know it's coming I think in 20
years it can be disproportionally it
could arbitrage the whole internet
itself I'm bullish I'm just short term I
care about timing timing is what matters
and so not a fan right now not a fan
right now
who is a young and upcoming entrepreneur
that you're watching out for that could
really be then F next Jeff Bezos I mean
at that level I'm not sure um I don't
know if I've seen it okay could be the
next Evan Spiegel so I don't you know I
don't have an answer I've also not been
investing a whole lot lately because I
the market is grossly overpriced for I
don't think ideas should be worth four
million dollars I'm a big fan of Rachel
tip of graph the founder of Micmac I
think she's a [ __ ] gangster what does
the company do
she's pivoted at six times in the last
15 minutes okay what does what what's up
it was a rigidly notable video it was
QVC for mobile then it became a SAS
product for brands mobile integration
swipe up shop ability in stories and
snapchat her tenacity is intoxicating
all right well that's a name that we'll
watch out for yeah I think that's you
know what's fun for me I don't think
that name populates for another 7 to 12
years but when I recall this clip on the
internet 7 to 12 years it's gonna feel
real good Gary Bitcoin or aetherium a
theorem why because it's more of a
platform than the singular brand its
blockchain and it's a theory and then
it's Bitcoin so I don't think people
understand right it's like it's like
WordPress and Netscape Navigator or
yahoo.com Bitcoin could win and can
become a brand like a Nike and could be
amazing and all that but theorem is the
infrastructure above which you build on
top of blockchain bless you blockchain
is the most gangster [ __ ] going on and
I'll explain why when you talk if you
truly understand the chess moves of
decentralizing everything well then the
whole damn world's on call governments
included so it could be interesting
what's one brand that's doing everything
it's supposed to and more that's hitting
it on all cylinders I've never been able
to answer this question and let me tell
you why I don't pay attention to other
brands so at Vayner when we have
Budweiser as a client this is now maybe
my team let me rephrase I hope my team
for Budweiser is looking at Miller Lite
and other things I I think a brand doing
everything right means that all their
behaviors are leading to a healthy
business not more likes when Burberry or
Taco Bell are getting all the accolades
then the press I never know if it's real
I understand that they're moving quickly
and doing good work on new stuff I just
don't know if it's actually dry
business there's a big disconnect
between being innovative and making
business decisions that are fruitful and
so I'm not sure but I would say the ones
that are spending the least amount of
money to make the most amount of money
in return money out versus money in how
would you advise let's say the NFL to
reclaim its glory it's under some
pressure these days how would you how
would you advise that you get its groove
back could it do it through social media
no no it's way way way way bigger than
that it's uh it's and it's not
concussions or President Trump it's so
many variables first of all fantasy
football dynamic has been really
intriguing because you've you've gotten
people to care more about players than
teams you've got the redzone channel is
such an incredible product like it's
completely addictive like it's just a
better experience if you love the sport
of football the mancave and the high
quality technology has made it so much
more interesting to be home than go to
the game but then when you're at home
people don't watch as much as they used
to yeah I mean I think you'd hit a
tipping point I mean like everybody like
like Jesus Christ it was like two years
ago like the NFL like what the NFL has
accomplished over the last couple years
is iconic all time like it it's you know
it's it's got so popular and now you
know soccer really you know the u.s.
going to the sweet 16 of two World Cups
in a row is a very subtle thing that
people underestimate right the you know
the distribution rights of the English
Premier League allowing kids to watch in
the mornings and go with their dad at 7
a.m. to do things is grossly
underestimated eSports is fundamentally
being disrespected for how big it
actually is and all of this is chopping
away at the the ratings it is still the
disproportionate most popular sport in
our country it's still doing incredibly
fine I think it is laughable to diss the
NFL for their business issues and
applaud NASCAR which has become
completely irrelevant like NASA cusine
its own ratings drop over the years long
before NASCAR has [ __ ] collapsed
well that's cars down half NASCAR is
over NASCAR doesn't even exist like so
it's like if we're talking like the
impact of stuff you know that's a
laughable argument the presents trying
to make NASCAR's finished eSports is
coming and and the NFL is you know where
baseball was in 1984 you know or 1973
it's like in that apex moment and you
know there's only one way to go from
that level how much closer are you to
your life goal of buying the Jets closer
and closer because I think the way I
play is very different than sucks or
other people which is I don't do any
behavior that creates quick massive
wealth I don't do the things that create
quick massive wealth I don't start
companies that could get to that level
I don't invest the level of capital that
can get to that level I'm running a
marathon a really long marathon but I'm
41 years old
right and so to me if I buy the Jets in
23 years I feel like I'm a young man I
feel like I hang out with a lot of 64
year old men and women who feel super
young to me and super on fire and have a
lot more to do and I think if I buy the
Jets at 64 that gives me plenty of time
to win seven Super Bowls in 30 years and
I can move on with very ambitious if you
can't get the Jets what's the next best
thing the mix all right the Johnsons and
the Dolans need to watch out um we're
gonna open this up to everyone in the
audience because I know you guys all
have questions for Gary we have
microphones so if you raise your hand
let me know and then we can this
gentleman in front will pass you a
microphone thank you so looking at
industries that I'm just in general
right now you see well it it's more like
a macro level yeah so you see like
blockbuster totally ignore Netflix yes
and now what's blockbuster what other
institutions do you see no kind of yeah
so what advice would you have for the
baby boomers and the executives today
who aren't paying attention to the tech
companies about what's coming tomorrow
yes Danny I think it's a different
conversation so let them hold it for a
second you're talking about those
decision
at those retail companies that aren't
doing the right thing to protect it I
don't think it's not it's not just
retail anymore well yeah I agree yeah
but like but what's the advice to the
people running them or the consumer I'm
just curious to the people running them
it it seems like right now they're not
listening to the Millennials and not
listening to the yeah it's not a minute
upstarts you know what it's about
it's about the fact that they are trying
to milk the next 24 to 36 months because
their bonuses and stock options and
their life when they're done running
this company is based on what the stock
price is in 24 months so they can buy
their yacht and their private jet and so
what all these CEOs are doing in public
companies is they're not being
incentivized properly for the health of
the company and we're living through the
biggest culture shift we've run because
we're living through a true revolution a
true industrial revolution so what's
happening is you can't I am not mad at
the fortune 5,000 CEOs because they're
human beings and what they're doing is
saying I'm gonna be in this world for
another 24 months I'm not gonna do the
thing that hurts the stock price by over
investing and having a shitty P&L to
invest a hundred million five hundred
million in the thing that needs I have
to put myself out of business before
somebody else does I'm not gonna do that
because I'm gonna have eight bad
quarters in a row I'm gonna be on this
network show every morning saying I suck
right and then I'm gonna get kicked out
and I'm gonna lose but Hershey's or
quicken or Hertz is gonna win they're
not dumb they're just selfish that's
about the short term this is I mean why
do big companies go out of business
because Wall Street exists so they're
not they know way more than you think my
man they know they just aren't
incentivized to do that this job they're
gonna retire with a lot of money bro
they're gonna they're gonna retire with
a lot of money right but if they listen
to you they're gonna retire with less
and that's why entrepreneurs have so
much opportunity because they're playing
a different game everything I do is for
the rest of my life for my legacy for my
family for myself so I care about my
as I care about my people cuz it's
forever not I'm gonna use this a
stepping stone to get on three public
boards and another to that so that's
what's happening that's real life
everybody knows it nobody talks about it
but when I talk about it all the people
shake their heads because everybody
knows that's what's happening with every
company that is trading and what this
building talks about all day long every
one of them do that every one of them do
that it's [ __ ] crazy but it's great
for me
because it's gonna allow me to buy great
brands for nickels on the dollar and I'm
excited about it
hi Gary thanks a big fan listen to you
all the time question what are your
thoughts on Airbnb and Home Sharing in
the future sort of lifestyle of nomadic
people visiting different places and so
on I think it will continue to grow I
think Brian's are really sharp see I
should also mention I'm I co-founded a
company haven't operated called resi
that just did a fairly big deal with
them Ben 11th all the CEO and Mike
Montero deserve all the credit I've been
I was in the idea phase in the capital
phase so I hope he continues to do well
because that's a big partnership what a
what a big one I have an email there's
another miss for me got an email from
Joe at AER bed-and-breakfast comm gear
garyvee I'm a huge fan we'd love for you
to see our startup never replied missed
it it's a good one
zoom I read it don't write it didn't go
into spam I didn't I I don't you I don't
know like I've one of my assistants
found it I didn't know if I had read it
or not read it all I know is it happened
and and I've got it in a folder when I
think I you know when when a planet II
apps launched and I was getting and I
was taking pictures with those three
famous people I went into that folder
and read all the things I mean mistakes
up I loved reminding myself that you
know about those things that matters
it's super interesting to me I mean you
know you start talking to start looking
at the world it gets real there's a lot
of arbitrage is coming man it's really
interesting out there and like as social
norms changes thing I'm most fascinated
by is how online dating went from you
are the weirdest nerd like what - the
absolute norm how you know I can't
believe how many well
if people would much rather have their
fourteen-year-old daughter go into
strange men cars every day versus drive
themselves
I mean if I sat here 15 years ago and
said I'm gonna make you one promise
because I live in the future all of you
are gonna think it's more safe for your
12 year old daughter to go into a
stranger's car every day than to drive
them like it's you know but that's our
norm like people of wealth send their
kids on ubers all day long and so I
think there's growth in that category
there's a lot of growth in the ability
of you know people arbitrage sawdust AWS
there's a lot of empty homes right
everyone has one well you know not
everyone has been what do you know today
there's a lot of [ __ ] empty homes
there's just a lot of empty homes bro
and a lot of empty a lot of things a lot
of sawdust left to go how are you doing
Gary have you thought about monetizing
your voice that's incredible yeah I'm a
speaker what's that I'm a speaker love
it's a great voice guy um if you can
give me two power moves to consumer
attention cuz you have basically
mastered the art of video everybody and
their mother watches you so if you give
me two power moves that you can use in
the next 24 hours to getting consumer
attention what would they be
I would become disproportionately
educated or act or start practicing very
aggressively in understanding how
Facebook Ads work Facebook ads are so
good you can create long tail clusters
42 year old Latino women that like the
New York Jets okay now go make a video
go make a Spanglish video about the jet
like the ability for the micro target at
scale right like you know I have a video
that went berserk Oh which was it was
basically I was getting mad that no
forty four-year-old thought themselves
as an ox like I was watching all the 19
and 20 year olds with all these
opportunities I'm like Jesus we're all
the 40 50 60 year-old it's like have you
heard you're gonna be living longer than
you think like let's go get ours
right so I made that video
and I went crazy because i targeted
forty to sixty year olds that watch
shark tank you know like like there's so
much capability in that i'd also you
know look I've got gift for gab
you've got crazy voice like you know
like you got to be smart about that like
the first three seconds really matter
the copy really matters the thumbnail
really matters everything matters I love
how people think these people the masks
millions of followers like because they
got lucky you know like there's so much
thought that goes into what we do a lot
of testing and learning but Facebook
video YouTube is hard to break out very
facebook video less hard especially if
you have a couple hundred bucks per
video to try to get it to go that's the
first power what about the second Power
Move for video if you're what would you
have interest in people that are under
30 I want all of their attention respect
so his voice is so [ __ ] rad
snapchat ads are grossly underpriced $3
CPMs that are watching a ton of video
once your ad comes in and if you got to
be very smart about the first second to
get them to swipe up and you can't say
swipe up cuz snapchat won't show it you
can get an unbelievable percentage of
people to watch three four minute videos
in the snapchat environment if you can
get them to snap swipe up and you can
get the most people under 30 for $3 CPMs
alright I'm doing that tonight right at
the yes thank you hi hi thank you
my name is Kirsten Broderick and I
founded a company called north scale
which is all about EQ I do executive and
corporate meditation training I love it
um so if anyone needs that if they would
you want to be the next Gary come check
me out hook hey um my question for you
is you said that Amazon might just do
the whole thing yeah and this is a
two-part question yeah what does that
mean
yep and what does that mean for the rest
of us not just the rest of us but the
global economy the global society the
environment yep
I think it means is you think about like
the pillars or at least the pillars I
think about when I talk about this kind
of stuff
retail media right social like I'd be
surprised if Amazon was in the social
business with a real play at some point
so those are three pillars that really
matter to me that I think about like
media in retail is like big right you
think about like how we live like as a
whole and I think that they you know I
don't Google retail and Facebook's
retail everybody else's retail is so far
behind it's not existent right their
ability to catch up in media has been
far quicker than the other people into
retail so you think about China where
full-stack they own it there's communism
dynamics there which is why it's
possible so anyway I just basically
think any business that Jeff Bezos wants
to get into he can I really believe that
I really think he could buy the Hilton
Group a Whole Foods is the preview not
the anomaly right so him if he wants to
and who know I don't know him at all I
don't know if the space is more
important than being considered the
greatest entrepreneur of a time I what
it means to all of us is the following
there is a massive naivete that we need
government to protect this issue
it's called innovation and capitalism
first of all Jeff Bezos is gonna die
second of all if VR comes out in 16
years and hits full penetration if we're
living in an augmented world of VR AR
and real life well then the entire
landscape of VR opportunity becomes open
its internet 1991 everything he's built
gets arbitrage if the way we actually
want to live is have protein pumped into
us and everything we buy is actually
happening virtually so I think there's a
naivete that anybody's ever gonna rule
the world I really do I really believe
that now not just how I see it I you
know I nobody's shown me in the history
of time that there may be able to
capture everything and sustain it
because they get that and the innovation
kills them not government that's how I
see it gentlemen standing in the back
I mean look for example real quick just
to put it into context it's I don't
think it's ever been a better time to be
in retail
just go direct to consumer Amazon's got
nothing to do with you
and then people cry uh you know Amazon
is too powerful don't sell it on Amazon
you loved it when it got you from 0 to 5
million right but now you're crying but
how'd you get there so get in there get
what you want take it out Facebook all
these media companies cry about Facebook
take people out people just aren't smart
really like all these media cookies
crying about Facebook make all your
content as a customer acquisition model
and then put them in your own bucket it
sounds so easy it is easy it's that once
again people that work in companies are
not incentivized the right way and it's
just human behavior the end hey Gary
thanks for coming my name is Rob Fajardo
I found a community called leave normal
behind travel around a bunch of
different masterminds and one of the
questions I have for you is as a
millennial being 23 you're being 41 yes
how have you found the ability to bridge
generations and the personalities of all
those generations when it comes to
assembling a team for business yeah you
know so first by not believing all the
propaganda around generational behavior
has been the way by one by one I know
plenty of 41 year old entitled lazy
people and I know that plenty of
Millennials that are working their
[ __ ] faces off one by one they're
just at your execution one by one oh
right I make no assumptions like the
thought that Millennials are entitled
and any lazier than all my lazy buddies
that I grew up with no shot you know
what I mean
I think it's convenient talk right I
think I think I think your generation is
the best I think you're the most
advanced socially this that the other
thing do I think a ton of you got eighth
place trophies yes and do I think that
that's why most likely it's harder for
you to beat me yes I believe that but
not all of you got eighth place trophies
I mean there was entitled kids and other
generations to like so it's about
strengths and weaknesses I think the
biggest undercurrent for the youth is
losing is a very good thing and we the
parents of these kids tried to protect
too much and which is really hurt that's
where America is vulnerable like at
scale
the political correctness of winning and
losing is a fundamentally dangerous
thing it a lot more than I think people
think losing matters and if you don't
get that gear you're deep [ __ ] and
entitlement is a real issue and lose
early and young god losing matters guys
like [ __ ] if you're a modern parent and
you're trying to protect that feeling
you're being selfish you don't like
seeing your kid upset I get it I have
them it sucks but you better [ __ ] get
out of the way because you're [ __ ] it
up because when you think you've won
when you came in eighth place that's
fine when you manipulated their grades
when you did their homework when you
diss that when you donated money and did
it enter there when they get to the real
world nobody gives a [ __ ] and that's
that's the cliche one thing that this
younger generation has worst it's a it's
definitely got as a whole as a macro
that's scary to me which is why I'm
going so aggressive because I have so
much of their attention right now in
this thing like it's good to lose I'm
proud of my loss ISM I am I like it I'm
notice some like talk about air be like
I want to bring up more like I don't
know I got tons of [ __ ] like like I love
losing I love the Jets and the Knicks I
gave up on the Yankees and Rangers cuz
they won I mean it I click like it's a
real thing like I'm proud of my losses
they're my losses the [ __ ] do you like
what's your losses
you've all got them like this notion and
so that one is big for everybody here
you need to be proud I try it at least
people are over 400 because they're
scared to leave I'll go with my 3 for 17
thanks Gary [ __ ] over here Thanks hi
Gary
ah my name is Dan I'm an investor in New
York awesome man uh as a millennial I
want to take umbrage with one of your
statements that I came in eighth eighth
place and got a trophy I actually came
in ninth and got a medal it's my
question you is regarding executive
compensation you were saying that when
you pay people with I guess two-year
vesting compensation they focus on the
next two years yes if you were to pay
them in kind of longer-term compensation
what would you do to avoid you know that
basically goofing off for seven years
and not really having anything to keep
them in check you know and saying no no
you gotta wait you gotta wait it'll hit
a little hit eventually that's a great
question uh I think that there's ways to
find a balance between those two
probably I haven't really thought about
it number two I think there can be
recourse you can like take away you can
take away equity along the way instead
of salary if they're goofing off for
seven and make the big payoff and ten we
have to if the biggest companies in the
world want to survive and the problem is
the boards in the same game so there's
no checks and balances but if they want
to if somebody has a motion for it we're
gonna have to make these much longer
things and I think you guys are a lot of
viewer in the game so right there's a
whole kind of conversation that seems
with some of the Silicon Valley talk of
like different compensations and
different ways to go public I saw a
headline just haven't started educating
myself
but it seemed that the energy eirick
grease baby from lean solder right so
something I'm trying to throw some stuff
out so somebody says you have shakes
their head but it seems like there seems
to be starting to be some early debate
of like it's not fun to go public for
Blue Bottle right it was the Blue Bottle
conversation that it seemed started some
conversations nonetheless yeah we're
gonna have to start figuring it I think
big companies are gonna have to start
figuring out how to get into ten year
things and then the argument of like
wooden then you're not gonna get the
best talent I think it's the other way
around you're not gonna get the best
talent by today's standards which I
think are career CEOs that suck and are
doing everything for themselves cool
thanks for the response mr. almond here
I'm not educated enough to answer that
question so that's the true answer I
would just throw one thing as a boy that
was born in communism you know the China
thing is super fascinating I've run the
gamut I've run the gamut of like we
grossly underestimate communism and like
its weaknesses but the more I think
about what China's doing China is
actually running the whole thing a lot
more like businesses or
right which is its a mix between
dictatorship and capitalism right like
there is an ultimate call or at the top
like it's really interesting like it's
been the theme in my head the last six
months I'm like wait a minute you know
like it I mean China runs China a hell
of a lot more like a success like Bezos
runs you know Amazon than the way we run
America which is like oh [ __ ] you know
like you know it's super fascinating so
I don't know I really don't I I but I
think it's uh I genuinely believe
intuitively that we are all very lucky
because I think we're gonna live through
some really interesting times over the
next twenty to forty years I think a lot
of people hearing that just expose
themselves to themselves let me explain
if you just heard that and you thought
that was bad it means you're pessimists
and you're on defense and if you heard
that and thought it was awesome means
you're an optimist and on offense and I
think most people are defensive
pessimists and I think that optimism and
gratitude and empathy are the
ingredients of the future winners and so
I'm glad my parents gave me that alright
Gary Vaynerchuk thank you so much I
really hope you guys enjoy that question
of the day before I sign off and send
you on your way what was the biggest
insight that you got from the talk you
just saw I promise I'm gonna read all
five six seven eight hundred comments
because this is the insight I'm looking
for so honest truth what was the biggest
takeaway from the talk that you just saw
[Music]
you
[Music]